[Musique]
oui bernard parent actrices emilie sa
mort lundi puis cette semaine
je tiens à vous remercier énormément par
rapport à votre support votre appui au
taux de l'enquète qui concerne le score
de jaycee chaque coin de par rapport à
la chronique que j'ai faite la semaine
dernière
c'est extrêmement apprécié d'avoir dû
sport mental moral et émotionnel autour
des enjeux aussi difficile bien sûr vous
pouvez imaginer l'emploi de tous les
témoignages qu'on a entendu et de
l'impact qu'ils ont sur les communautés
sur notre notre capacité aussi des pas
aller de l'avant parce qu'on se dit mais
est-ce qu'on va toujours faire ce genre
de lutte là et ça m'a amené à réfléchir
à qu'est-ce qui nous guérit qu'est-ce
qui nous soignent dans les communautés
ces leviers très souvent avec le
territoire avec la nature et ce lien le
sera et négligé ou n'est pas aussi bien
enseigner qu'on devrait le faire donc
aujourd'hui j'ai plus redonné vraiment
un espace mental aux forêts aux arbres
et pourquoi je parle des forêts des
arbres est bien c'est que j'ai vu une
photo
sortez de faire une chronique qui est
une lieu où c'est en
colombie-britannique on a vu la coupe
forestière d'arbres ancestrales et une
image qui fait le tour justement des
médias sociaux
c'est l'image d'un seul arbre énorme
dans un camion un entraînement aussi
tellement gros que on peut pas le
transporter autrement que seul tout seul
dans un camion donc c'était de se dire à
quel point on est capable d'abattre les
cathédrales naturel les statuts
naturelles qui existent et avec lequel
on collabore et qu'on vit depuis des
milliers d'années sur ce territoire
haussier pour en faire parfois du papier
toilette goûter à la cuisine mais vous
comprendrez que la perte de ces
monuments là me fait autant réagir que
quand on a vu brûler notre dame à paris
et c'est un écho que l'on peut voir
aussi au québec quand on regarde les
camions qui sortent des forêts du québec
et que les armes sont de plus en plus
petits puisque on a tellement
mais qu'il nous reste à peine deux
jeunes verts donc pourquoi je dis ça
vous comprendre que c'est un enjeu
financier au québec et c'est un enjeu
aussi d'une culture autour de
l'idéologie du bûcheron mais c'est aussi
un enjeu touché communauté autochtone et
la relation à la forêt l'arbre était un
être vivant à un être avec quelqu'un on
avait des relations deux frères et
soeurs de ça le fera je pense tout
simplement car qui ajoute qu'en est il
s'est perdu
c'est qu'elle joue c'est qu'une ancienne
les gens nous voient ce que il se fait
arroser par la mouffette mais pour
retrouver son chemin jusqu'à l'océan
pour se laver les yeux
il a été dirigé par les arbres et chats
car dépendant de la forêt d'où il venait
lui indiquer le chemin et c'est comme ça
qu'on savait qu'elle retrouve dans
quelle forêt je pense aussi à un arbre
qui apparaît à notre naissance et on
parle souvent du classement un peu et
quand on regarde le placenta une faux
étendue on voit un arbre les racines on
voit les branches et c'est ce qui nous a
portés jusque dans le monde des vivants
et je vais même pas aller jusque avec la
femme céleste qui est tombé du ciel en
creusant au pied de l'arbre de vie pour
trouver les racines qui guérissent et
qui a créé la terre il met donc une
relation à l'art au naturel aux êtres
vivants qui malheureusement n'est pas
toujours donné à tout le monde de
connaître des gens mais les jambes ne
sont pas toujours en lice et
malheureusement cette déconnexion le
fait qu on sent un vide est consciente
des connexions donc on tournant vers la
nature qu'en tournant vers la forêt en
tournant vers les frères nos frères qui
pousse nos frères qui volent nos frères
qui nagent nos frères qui marche
eh bien je trouve une guérison par
rapport à des situations où est ce que
la relation avec nos frères humains
des fois peut être déconnecté donc je
vous invite cette semaine allaient
explorer la nature aussi petite soit
elle ou s'il y connecter sur tel que ce
soit en milieu urbain que ce soit à
l'extérieur pour pouvoir vous reconnais
que picard on ne pense à travers une
étape extrêmement difficile de notre
société
le confinement on pense encore à travers
des étapes très difficiles tels que les
enjeux de société avec ses chaque mois
la dernière enjeu de société mais de
reconnecter avec nounous vraie relation
et de voir que un arbre qui pousse à
plus d'impact bénéfique dans nos vies un
art qui coupait uniquement pour faire de
victimes alors je souhaite une semaine
j'espère que ça va vous inspirer à
sortir dehors
j'espère que vous avez partagé cette
famille bonne semaine